eeuu prometió aumentar el dolor sobre el
kremlin con un nuevo paquete de
sanciones así lo anunció el presidente
estadounidense joe biden a quien se le
quebró la voz al hablar de las
atrocidades cometidas por parte de las
fuerzas rusas contra la población civil
en boots a cerca de la capital ucraniana
primero eeuu va a imponer sanciones de
bloqueo total al sporting por lejos la
institución financiera más grande de
rusia y al alza bank su banco privado
más grande vamos a bloquear cualquier
cuenta y fondo que esos bancos tengan en
eeuu no van a poder tocar su dinero no
van a poder hacer ningún negocio aquí
segundo voy a firmar una orden ejecutiva
que va a prohibir cualquier inversión
estadounidense en rusia
las sanciones de washington apuntan a
las dos hijas del presidente ruso
vladimir putin como respuesta a lo que
consideran crímenes de guerra cometidos
en las cercanías de kiev reino unido por
su parte sumó la imposición de sanciones
a otros ocho oligarcas rusos y
culminarán las importaciones de petróleo
y carbón rusos para el próximo año
nuestras nuevas sanciones debilitarán
aún más la economía rusa poner fin a las
importaciones de energía rusa activos
lados del banco más grande de rusia y
seberbank prohibición total de nuevas
inversiones en el extranjero a rusia la
unión europea apunta hacia la presión en
el sector energético de moscú bruselas
del paso intentando culminar su
dependencia de los combustibles fósiles
rusos pero sin mencionar por ahora al
gas first en primer lugar impondremos la
prohibición de importar carbón de rusia
por valor de 4.000 millones de euros al
año y en worcester ya los expertos
citados por la casa blanca apuntan a que
esta nueva oleada de sanciones sumadas a
las anteriores supondrán que el pib de
rusia se contraiga hasta un 15% este año